here's California Congressman Eric
swalwell he is a really really uh he's
just an idiot he he's an idiot he's a
bad dude he's one of these people that
calls everyone racist uh he also 100 for
sure was sleeping with a Chinese spy uh
when I had Kevin McCarthy the GOP leader
on the show he laid out all of the
details you can find the video maybe
we'll play it in the next day or two if
something else with swallow pops up but
so Eric swallow who has slept with a
Chinese spy a Chinese spy who then
helped staff his office and then he got
on intelligence committees I mean it's
crazy stuff he's one of the absolute
worst on the Democrat side he put up
this ad on abortion and it's it's I'm
actually sorry that I have to show it to
you but here we go
[Music]
you're weird he is weird but cute
oh
Mary Anderson yes I have a warrant for
your arrest a rest for what penal code
243 violation unlawful termination of a
pregnancy you've got to be kidding me
that that is my personal business that's
for the courts to decide man your
medical records have been subpoenaed and
Dr Landry's already in custody
no
my God you you can't just you will have
to submit to a physical examination
what
no no no one's touching it
man turn around put your hands behind
your back now why is this happening
love you honeybear
we're just enforcing the law here
elections have consequences vote
Democrat on November 8th stop
Republicans from criminalizing abortion
everywhere
protect women's rights and freedom
please don't do this please
Eric swalwell you are an extraordinary
piece of [ __ ] like what else how can I
analyze this in any more now immediate
gonna write a thing Dave Rubin called
swallow a piece of [ __ ] so swallow by
the way who farted live on MSNBC
remember that one did that the president
use taxpayer dollars to ask the
ukrainians to help him cheat an election
Chris Matthews then they pretended it
was a coffee cup moving on the desk
um you see what I'm saying about this
thing where all they have is fear that
that is a bad dystopian science fiction
movie he just made right there
all they have is fear do you know that
virtually every single even the most ex
I don't like the word extreme related to
this but even the most pro-life
politicians in America uh have certain
caveats for abortion in the case of rape
or incest etc etc places like Florida I
keep saying this which is thought of as
now this radical right-wing Freedom
loving very scary place has 15 weeks on
abortion that is the moderate position
and that Senator Rubio who voted for it
he personally in his life is pro-life
our governor Ron DeSantis he personally
is pro-life but Florida as a red state
has made a compromise at 15 weeks 15
weeks again which is three and a half
months okay we're well past heartbeat
we're past organs being developed and
all of those things and then you know
they're also trying to do things like
have these pregnancy centers where women
could come in and say you know I'm
really struggling with this I don't have
the the family to back me up and help me
out I don't have the finances so then
there are these pregnancy centers where
they try to help people so that they
could then give them up for adoption or
figure out other ways that they could
maybe get some donations Etc et cetera
and then what happens the Democrats
Elizabeth Warren we've shown you the
video
they call this evil